moving forward
steps need to protect our own democracy
and on the point of the former president
he did respond to president biden's
speech and he called it quote political
theater what is your response
well it looks like he saw the speech i
guess that's good news maybe he learned
something about what it looks like to
to meet the moment in the country
to meet the moment where people are
hurting
they're thinking of the pain all of the
people who worked in that capital who
were there a year ago whether they were
members of congress their staff janitors
or journalists and to speak to who we
can be and call for people's uh higher
powers to reach that maybe he learned
something from that i guess we'll see
about the big picture today jen which is
that
most of the people who attended these
ceremonies today were democrats there
were some republican lawmakers you do
have this pushback from the former
president and from some of his
supporters and polls show that there are
still a number of republicans who
believe that the election
was stolen from the former president
does president biden feel as though he's
done enough to unify the country and
what more does he need to do given the
sharp divides that we still see on
display today
well i would say kristin that i don't
think calling this uh the events of
today
a partisan issue or suggesting that we
have reached a partisan point is doing
justice to the tens of millions of
republicans independents and others out
there who don't feel that way
we're talking about some republicans in
congress not all many far too many who
in our view in the president's view need
to take a look at themselves and think
about what
role they want to play in the history
books when their children and
grandchildren look at the history books
do they want to be perpetuating the big
lie do they want to be
walking uh like silent lemmings behind
the former president and from and who
fomented an insurrection or do they want
to be part of saving our democracy so
the question really should be directed
at them and that's our view
go ahead thanks jen um six former
advisory board members from the biden um
health transition
wrote three opinion pieces in a medical
article um calling for a new pandemic
strategy that sort of embraces
living with the new normal of kobe being
endemic and they said previous claims
that we've gained the upper hand you
know now look short-sighted and we need
to change our understanding of what
success is and what kind of target we're
looking at
has the president
has the president been advised on
whether it's likely that we will have to
live with covid
in some form or another forever
by his current team
i have not had the opportunity it's
obviously been a busy day to read these
articles i'm happy to do that and i
don't believe the president has um i
think i answered the question a little
bit earlier in terms of advice given by
his health and medical experts i'd
really point you to them to ask them
that question and just sort of following
up on darlene's question just
does the president believe that cobit is
here to stay
again the president's goal is to defeat
the virus
the president's focus and objective now
is to save as many lives as possible
know what works i know that
pushing more people getting more people
vaccinated getting more people boosted
encouraging mask wearing making sure
schools have the resources they need to
stay open and do that in a safe way
these are steps that work it means
surging capacity to communities that are
hard harder hit hardest hit it means
opening federal testing sites around the
country there are a number of steps
we're taking day to day to save more
lives reduce hospitalization and that's
what our focus is on the experts also
wrote that vaccine mandates should be
imposed more broadly including for
school children has the administration
heard those concerns and is that
something that they're weighing are more
mandates possible well those decisions
are related to schools and i haven't
read the articles and i'm happy to but
we'll always be up to local school
districts in terms of what steps need to
be taken and some have taken some steps
some have not but those will always be
decisions up to local school districts
and then the latest cdc data shows that
the omicron variant accounts for
95 of the country's cases right now uh
there's also data to show that
two shots is ineffective at um
protecting against this variant so what
is the point of calling someone fully
vaccinated with only that primary series
of shots
if the science is showing that that's
not enough to protect them
well jackie what the cdc is advising is
for everyone to be up to date on their
shots that means if you're
scheduled at that point to have a
booster you should get a booster uh and
that is true that is how they conduct
their guidance for basically any shot
regimen uh for childhood diseases
measles mumps rubella whatever it may be
uh but i would point you to them for
more specifics on where they are on what
fully vaccinated looks like they've
obviously just provided additional
guidance wouldn't there then at some
point though be sort of a gap between
fully vaccinated and up to date
and just just looking at the two
definitions they're encouraging you to
be up to date and most people are
eligible for shots if you're over the
age of five or booster shots um you know
at a certain point in time given
the waning
protection of you know the primary
series of vaccines and the need to get
boosters in a shorter time period won't
there come a time where they're not
really fully vaccinated anymore with
just two shots well when by up to date
they're advising people if they're due
for a booster they should get a booster
go ahead thank you not to believe at
this point but back to dartmouth sure
first question um
as you said the president has often
discussed the threat to our democracy
given that threat given the stakes that
he laid out today why not be more
forceful
throughout this year why wait until the
anniversary to deliver such a harsh
rebuke
well
again i would say the president in our
view has not backed down
ever at any point from making clear
about the need to protect our democracy
to protect the fundamental right to vote
which he feels is a key part of that he
also believes that delivering on what
the american people uh wanted when they
sent him to govern
requires him and and it was essential
for him to address the core issues that
they're facing every day of course that
includes protecting their fundamental
rights that also includes beating the
pandemic getting americans back to work
and he knows that in order to restore
faith in government and institutions uh
in people's belief that government can
actually work for them that solving
those problems and working to solve
those problems needed to be his first
and second priorities why wait till
today to speak about the former
president in such stark terms like he
did today again this is not about one
person even the former president
obviously today is an anniversary of an
incredibly one of the darkest days in
our democracy
the president i know from talking to him
this afternoon felt that personally he
felt the emotion of the people he saw in
the capitol today he felt the weight on
the shoulders of the people who were
there that day who were there again
today
but his view is that this is about
looking at this moment as an inflection
point not just about a former president
but about who we are as a country
whether republicans in congress are
going to step up what the american
people can be assured of in terms of his
efforts to fight for the protection of
their fundamental rights it's bigger
than a former president you mentioned
voting rights uh majority leader schumer
has vowed to hold a vote to change
senate rules to pass voting rights by
mlk day
given the urgency that the president
laid out today to protecting the right
to vote will we see the president
directly endorse a rule change before
then
the president um
will speak next tuesday as you know and
he said right before christmas that if
that is a change that needs to happen
that he would support that uh but i'll
have more to say next tuesday
senator manchin has signaled that he may
be willing to support a rule change is
that something the president has
discussed with him in recent days i will
let senator manchin speak for himself on
where he stands on that did you have
another one i did i wanted to go back to
another topic real quick okay sorry
struck up the manhattan district
attorney
has uh ordered prosecutors to stop
seeking prison sentences for certain
crimes uh including resisting arrest and
i'm just wondering does that give the
wrong message to criminals or to
police who are having to enforce these
laws the district attorney is not going
to prosecute and does this in any way
undermine the bind administration's
efforts through the doj and federal law
enforcement partners to crack down on
crimes like retail theft well you know
where we stand on supporting local
police officers local
cops
and not defunding the police and also
our concerns we have about the retail
thefts we have seen and the need for
leaders and communities to crack down on
that i have not spoken obviously with
our legal team or of course the
department of justice about this
particular issue i can see if there's
more we can add i don't have all the
details go ahead
thanks um first i just wanted to check i
know you guys have said uh towards the
end of this week on finalizing the
contracts for the rapid test if those
have been signed yet
i expect we'll have more in the next 24
hours
and as soon as we do and as soon as
there are more details to report we will
let you all know that's what we're
working on right now do you remain
confident that
you know if you don't even have the
contract signed yet that you'll be able
to actually set up a website ship them
out
um have them available by the end of the
month which is your sort of state of the
goal absolutely i mean remember a lot of
these things are happening
simultaneously right uh we issued the
request for proposal that closed just a
couple of days ago we worked to find
we've been working to finalize the
contracts and as we said and we're on
track for this we'll be uh issuing uh
some of the first rewards uh for that
awards uh for that uh very soon um and
we'll have an update on that i think
very shortly and we want we don't want
to put the website up before we know we
can uh provide even even through
pre-orders um tests as people want to
request them um the postal service is at
social for a temporary waiver um on
their vaccine mandate i'm wondering what
the response from the white house is
they've said that if they don't get the
waiver it could impact males for this
well uh i would say just to remind
everybody two months ago more than two
months ago osha issued an emergency
temporary standard to protect warfare
workers from the spread of coronavirus
on the job everywhere
at companies including the postal
service and the agency found that
compliance with the rule was feasible
for all employers including the postal
service that was two months ago osha
provided several compliance resources to
help employers develop vaccine or
testing requirement programs and
understand the responsibilities under
the emergency temporary standard
including fact sheets template plans for
employers other online resources a
webinar that walks through the
obligations employers and information to
help them come into in compliance
we know osha's mission is to ensure
every working person in the country has
safe and healthy working environments
including the postal service so we will
let osha speak to any response to the
letter but again i just wanted to remind
people that when it was issued it was
made clear that uh the postal service
could be compliant and had the ability
to do that and still conduct their jobs
okay so just one last question
the president today i've made pretty
clear that um
you know
his push for uh legislation protect
voting rights
um but there's an effort among some
senators to address what happened last
year uh
through reforming the electoral account
act
i know that you guys have made clear
that it's not a substitute for what you
want but
are you supportive of that effort in and
of itself or do you think that it
distracts sort of from the larger
objective
well i think it's really important for
people who aren't watching this as
closely as you and i to understand that
uh that is not a substitute for the
protections that are included in the
freedom to vote act and the john lewis
voting rights advancement act that is
why our focus is on those and just as a
reminder the freedom to vote act creates
standards for voter access and voter
registration uh outlines criteria to
make redistricting laws less partisan
strengthens campaign finance laws the
john lewis voting rights act establishes
a new pre-clearance process to ensure
that certain states and jurisdictions
need approval for the department of
justice from the department of justice
before moving forward with changes that
impact voting rights these are all
important protections given the
insistence by far too many republicans
out there in using the big lie as an
excuse to make it more difficult for
people to vote so it is not a
replacement it is not a substitute and
our focus remains on those two pieces of
legislation go ahead jen florida
governor ron desantis critiqued the fine
administration's at-home testing program
and said that not every single person
needs to be getting tested
that's not a good strategy but what is a
good strategy is to have those at-home
tests available for our vulnerable
population and quote he says that he'll
be sending tests to nursing homes
long-term care facilities and within
senior communities so does the white
house have any plans to limit tests
through the website it'll be launching
to vulnerable communities and what's
your response to governor desantis well
i would first say that we have taken a
number of steps to provide tests at a
much larger expansive
capacity than that to vulnerable
communities across the country that has
been part of the president's effort to
quadruple our testing capacity to
provide the 5 million tests to community
health centers rural health centers
and to work with local health officials
to ensure that we're reaching
communities that need help the most and
that is part of our commitment to
approaching our effort to get the
pandemic under control through uh
through the lens of equity uh i would
say it's pretty rich coming from
governor desantis given he is somebody
who's been uh advocating uh not exactly
advocating for people in his state to
get vaccinated which uh we know is the
way that people can be protected way
that lives can be saved and if he wants
to be a constructive part of this
process then perhaps he should encourage
what scientists say is the best way to
save lives prevent and reduce
hospitalization and that is getting
vaccinated and getting boosted voting
rights you you've talked several times
today about how the president will make
the case on tuesday that the country is
at an inflection point but democrats
such as rep eric swalwell say they're
worried that if republicans win in the
midterm elections that voting as we know
it in this country will be gone does the
president share that opinion well i'm
not going to get ahead of an outcome of
midterm elections that is many months
away what our focus is on now is getting
voting rights legislation passed and
signed into law and calling out as
congressman suawell has
the fact that opposition the four times
that republicans in congress in the
senate have prevented even a vote on
voting rights legislation is obstruction
that is not the senate working that is
why there's a discussion right now about
changes to senate rules to protect the
constitutional rights of people across
the country that's why we're having this
discussion but i'm not going to make
predictions about a midterm election and
the impact
go ahead
jen the president made very clear today
that he assigns responsibility to
president trump
for the january 6 riot in this erection
he didn't really talk though about what
consequences he thinks the president the
former president i should say should
face
what consequences does he think he
should face he's going to leave that to
his justice department which is
independent
and
the the january 6 committee does he have
any expectation or hope or desire
for what they may or may not do with
regard to the former president we are
going to continue to work uh to support
their efforts to support uh the
important work that committee is doing
uh but he's not gonna prejudge the
outcome of that committee either
vice president harris in her remarks
today compared january 6 to pearl harbor
at 9 11. can you elaborate on what the
thinking was behind that comparison
she's faced some criticism especially in
conservative circles for that
well i would first say that um as the
president also said in his remarks uh
you know when if we look back to some
very difficult moments in our history
back in 1861 there were no confederate
flags being being waived in the capital
in very dark moments in our history
there were not people storming our
nation's capital uh trying to take over
the office and even threatened the
speaker of the house um so instead of
for those who are being critics of the
vice president's remarks i think instead
of focusing on or analyzing comparisons
of moments in history i would suggest
that they be a part of uh solving the
threats of democracy that occurs today
that is happening today
and they are using this as an excuse not
to be a part of that
one more topic
does the white house or the president
have any
position or if you weighed in at all in
the
sort of growing row now between
australia and serbia over the tennis
star whose name i won't try to
mispronounce uh who's there now and is
apparently unvaccinated i don't believe
we have weighed in on that i can
certainly check with the state
department and our national security
team and see if we have a position to
share go ahead uh thanks jen um texas
this week received about 2 400 horses of
antibody therapy which given the omicron
surge is not going to meet demand
can you explain how these allocations
are decided and when they will increase
they will continue to increase um they
are done equitably across the country
and to meet needs where they where we
have them there are obviously needs in
texas but
there is nothing accurate in any
reporting i'm not suggesting this is
from you uh that we have held back that
we have canceled that we have prevented
uh obviously the um the availability of
antibody antiviral treatments is not
unlimited we're continuing to build on
the supply we have and we'll continue it
to distribute that equitably to states
and communities across the country and
following on with jeff's question about
consequences yeah
the president
characterized today characterized the
january 6 attack as an armed
insurrection and of course he blamed
former president trump for inciting the
insurrection
no one has been charged for insurrection
which is a specific crime is does the
president want the justice department to
press charges of insurrection against
trump or anyone else the president wants
the justice department and the attorney
general to act independently as the
attorney general demanded when he
accepted the job and as the president
expected and demanded from any attorney
general he was going to select i mean
you can leave the decision-making to the
justice department and the attorney
general but this
i mean he did characterize
the attack today as a specific kind of
crime that that is his view he was not
making a judgment about or direction of
what the justice department should do or
how they should behave or act and i
don't think that the justice department
or the attorney general sees that he did
either
go ahead yeah thanks jim looking ahead
again to tuesday's speech in atlanta how
will president biden's case for voting
rights legislation be any different than
the many arguments we've heard him make
before
in favor of that legislation
well he has made many arguments uh in
favor of voting rights legislation
before now we he is going to be
delivering uh this speech at a time
where it is uh going to be under active
discussion and debate in the senate uh
which is an important component and in
the week leading up to martin luther
king day which is an important moment to
remember and recognize many of the
sacrifices
that important leaders in our history
have made i will say he's going to
georgia because georgia is one of the
many states where corrupt acts on the
constitutional right to vote and the
integrity of elections have taken place
uh based on the big lie it was also
pivotal to the civil rights movement
it's important to underline that while
these un-american efforts are being
driven by the big lie they are also in
line with some of the worst episodes of
the past but what i think you will hear
him say and the vice president of course
talk about as well is about the urgent
need to pass legislation to protect the
constitutional right to vote and the
integrity of our elections he'll talk
about the specifics and he's very
focused on people in the country
understanding and knowing uh what is in
this legislation why is it so important
to pass these pieces of legislation what
is at risk what needs to be protected
and i think you'll hear him talk about
that and he also wants to of course
restore the senate working
which is not happening right now as is
evidenced by the fact that they have
blocked even the ability to vote on
voting rights legislation four times so
he'll outline all of that but he will
make a passionate case as he has made as
you said in the past uh for why we need
to move forward with voting rights
legislation earlier the briefing you
referenced i think was on abc an
interview that yeah uh president biden
has before uh new year's in which he
said he was open for uh senate rule
changes changes to the filibuster uh you
pointing that out are you indicating
that he will be bringing up the
filibuster and senate rules during this
speech on tuesday i don't have any more
to preview the speech but i expect he
will continue to talk about
what he's willing to support and do
should that be needed to move voting
rights legislation forward looking to
clarify the white house's position
on the united states postal service's
request for
uh a waiver from the map from the uh
the vaccine mandate from osha uh you
know does the white house
support that request or oppose we'll let
osha respond to the letter that was sent
directly to them from the postal service
i was just reiterating the fact that at
the time when the announcement was made
uh it was also determined that uh the
entities that would be it would be
applicable to in the government
including the postal service had every
ability to implement it at one point
the united states united states postal
service made in its letter to osha was
quote
this mandate is quote likely to result
in the loss of many employees either by
employees leaving or being disciplined
does those do those concerns uh you know
explain why demonstrate why this mandate
could be problematic for many businesses
out there well we know that more than 60
percent of businesses on their own
accord have implemented vaccine
requirements or testing requirements
they've all implemented it in different
ways many many have done it incredibly
successfully and they have done it
because they want to create a safe
working environment where people feel
comfortable and confident in going to
work
and that to them to companies across the
country to the united states military
even is a priority uh in order to ensure
their workplace and their workforce feel
safe as we've said many times around
these requirements when we announce them
our objective here is to not punish but
to protect people to save more lives to
make people feel more safe and
comfortable in the workplace and as a
part of the process uh there is a
process of um of consulting with
individuals who are not yet vaccinated
uh and there's not a cliff that is not
the intention here and that is the same
in terms of how it would be applied
question on the different types of going
to colorado tomorrow before we that goes
to the bottom resources what can we
expect to see from president tomorrow in
colorado as he visits the
devastating fire today well i think
we're still finalizing all the details
but uh he will of course visit with what
i would you can expect him i should say
to visit with local elected officials
who have been obviously dealing with the
aftermath and the many families who have
been going through a devastating time
with homes lost communities lost um he
typically engages and meets with seized
families while he's on these trips as
well and i would expect that to be a
part of the visit tomorrow and then i
would suspect he would also uh deliver
some remarks but we're just finalizing
the details of what it will look like
sure go ahead thanks jen um first of all
kind of a semi housekeeping question and
then one about air travel
first off last month finally uh dozens
of ambassadors were confirmed by the u.s
senate um but so far only one person
believes that we know so the first
league chief of staff and now the
ambassador to spain and andorra is
getting the traditional swearing in with
the vice president um there's one that
was on the calendar originally yesterday
for cindy mccain that apparently didn't
happen are this being postponed or
cancelled is this related to concerns
about omicron
so um it is true that some people have
been sworn in here at the white house
others have been sworn in by leaders in
their own communities and as you
reference some haven't been sworn in at
all yet there's no set ceremonial way or
requirement i should say of swearing in
of ambassadors or how it has to take
place and everyone does it a little bit
differently we've of course yes as we're
as we're looking and and continuing to
battle kovid a new variant um we've kept
many of these types of gatherings
smaller in size at the white house
because of that
but i don't think there's really one
reason as to why they're different they
are typically all different um and
expect they will continue to be okay and
on air travel um earlier this month the
faa released data revealing that unruly
passenger incidents were higher than any
other year in modern aviation history
and that 70 percent of those incidents
were related to they were called mass
related um you've talked about keeping
vaccine mandates for air travel limited
to people who are not from the united
states coming into the united states but
has there been any consideration that a
vaccine mandate for domestic air travel
could potentially reduce the likelihood
of these types of incidents of people
getting upset on air on flights
i have not heard that explanation
internally there's obviously a range of
factors that our health and medical
experts look at and they have not yet
advised at this point the president on a
requirement of vaccines domestically uh
the reason they have given is of course
that inter requirement for international
travel travelers helps
reduce and delay
variance
or
spreading to the united states and we
know that masking is very effective
according to our health experts and
protecting people on flights so i have
not heard that um that explanation or
argument being made by um by our health
and medical experts i would i may point
you to the faa or the dot if they think
that is a relevant argument
okay i have not heard that argument here
go ahead hi jen a couple questions for
you uh one as we speak right now 350 000
kids school kids in chicago remain out
of school
most are black hispanic and our poor
this administration has called for
equity in education
so who does the body administration
blame for failing these young kids
well first of all the president has been
very clear he wants these schools to be
open
including in chicago and including
across the country
that we took steps early on in the
pandemic even against skeptics who
didn't think we needed this funding in
the american rescue plan to pass 130
billion dollars that has already been
distributed to states
and gone to many schools across the
country to put in place mitigation
measures it hasn't been applied
everywhere but a lot of states have used
this and a lot of communities have used
this very effectively so he would like
to see schools open
he believes that not having them open as
you've touched on impacts the mental
health of children we've seen that we
know that learning gaps is something
that we are seriously at risk of at this
point in time and that's why we'll
continue to call for schools to open 96
are open across the country and are
doing the right thing
directly involved at a certain point how
many days have to go by before he jumps
in well we have we are in regular touch
with uh teachers uh school
administrators labor leaders across the
country
nearly every single day including in
chicago and that that will continue and
we will continue to make the case for
schools to be open another question
please on religious freedom
does president biden believe doctors and
religious health care providers should
be forced to perform medical procedures
that violate their conscience rights and
religious beliefs
i believe there are exemptions in some
cases i'm not sure what you're referring
to specifically why don't you give me a
little bit
in st louis the court of appeals just
heard oral arguments on a case involving
religious health care providers who
object to performing gender transition
procedures
i would point you that sounds like
that's a legal case that's underway that
i'm not going to weigh into from here
last one just a few weeks from now
you're in dc the march for life arrives
thousands of people will be here
supporting unborn children its theme
this year is equality begins in the womb
this administration talks a lot about
equality does the president agree with
that statement
the president believes in a woman's
right to choose i think you're very
familiar with his position on this issue
go ahead thanks jen um beyond just the
former president there have been several
democrats sorry several republicans
today
um who have accused the president of um
political theater um exploiting the
january 6th riots
um for political game you said you
talked to the president um after his
speech i'm curious
what his feeling was if he's seen the
response to um his speech and how he
felt feels like it whatever
well i i would first say
we didn't talk about the
desperate
uh comments of many republicans
suggesting that commemorating a dark day
in our democracy and calling for all of
us to protect people's fundamental
rights
including the peaceful transfer of power
people's right to vote
across the country
we didn't talk much about um attempts to
distract by some republicans in congress
um
uh what i can tell you and i talked
about this touch on this a little bit
earlier is that what he was really
touched by i mean he is somebody who i
think we've said i know we talk about
him being in the senate a lot but on a
day like this it's especially
important he served in that uh chamber
for 36 years uh
the people who work there are his
friends are his family um not just
senators but staff and people have been
working on committees custodians people
who work in the lunchrooms
and he was really impacted by the sheer
emotion of a day like this and the fact
that it is still a trauma for many
people who live through this day
journalists included and he talked about
that in his speech today
a year ago uh so that was really what
what weighed on him and you know he also
talked about um the importance of
not allowing this day to be buried in
history and he said that in his speech
today but it's important that we not
allow attempts to distract by some uh or
attempts to move on by others uh to
prevent us from taking steps to protect
people's fundamental rights and today is
a reminder of that
and kind of on a a different topic um
with recent announcements of house
democrats deciding not to run for
re-election it's up to about it's now
over two dozen i'm curious um what the
president's
thinking is on that how much he's
involved in the discussions of how to
um kind of counter that keeping control
of the house
well as i've said before i've learned my
lesson about not speaking about politics
from the podium so i'm not going to do
that from here but what i can tell you
the president is focused on and feels
confident in is
any democrat out there
in the house they all run every two
years right
they will be out there talking about um
what they have done to rebuild roads and
rails and bridges across the country to
restore broadband to ensure kids have
clean drinking water a handful of
republicans will be able to do that too
but not many uh and they will be able to
talk about how we are fighting for and
hopefully we'll have passed uh efforts
to put in place universal pre-k uh
efforts to uh cut the cost of child care
elder care and make sure that we're
investing in addressing the climate
crisis every uh it is about a choice in
this country and uh we'd rather be us
than them in that case go ahead
a foreign policy question
an iranian naval commander has
threatened the us forces and asked him
to leave the strait of hormuz how does
the white house see this threat
and it has been an escalation recently
by the pro-iran militias in iraq and
syria against u.s presence do you think
in the long run that will push the us uh
to an administration to take a decision
to leave iraq and syria
well uh let me first say that i know
there's been a lot of reporting
including of course from your outlet out
there but here officially uh we don't
have any specific attribution um
today in terms of the particular group
by name or groups who might be
responsible for this we don't have
anything new on that front
as my colleague john kirby said
yesterday from the podium at the
department of defense these sorts of
attacks are very much typical of what we
have been seeing in recent months
and they've been increasing
even years by even by militia groups
that are supported
by iran but in terms of specifics such
as the name of groups or groups a group
or groups we don't believe we don't have
that level of detail at this point uh in
terms of intent uh it's also also
difficult because of that for us to
ascribe intent with any real specificity
uh or certainty in these types of
attacks uh we can't say definitively who
caused them or why the attacks seem to
have stepped up it is certainly possible
uh that it can be related to the talks
in vienna or the anniversary of the
solemnani strike
but again right now we're still
assessing uh attribution we're still
assessing uh intent uh so we don't have
much more analysis at this point in time
okay thanks everyone
[Laughter]
you